a vaccine is the type of treatment for a
disease which alerts the immune system
and causes the immune system to start to
act against the disease a drug on the
other hand is a molecule of some type
which is able to treat the symptoms of
the disease our goal is to develop
interventions that can help save and
protect the Tasmanian devils in the wild
we're trying to develop a vaccine which
can help to prevent those Devils in the
wild from getting the disease secondly
we're interested in developing a drug
which can help cure those Devils that
already have signs of the disease and
also prevent them from spreading it
further to other devils so I think a
combination of these two approaches are
really essential for saving the
Tasmanian devils in the wild the really
good thing about our immune system is
that it remembers particular pathogens
so the way that we hope to make a
vaccine against devil facial tumour
disease is to take these tumor cells in
the lab and to make them express very
particular molecules or proteins on the
surface of their cells and then we would
treat these DFTD cells in some way to
make them non harmful to the devils so
basically stop them growing that means
that when we put them back into the
Devils
they won't divide and they won't cause
tumors but what they will do is they
will allow the immune system to have a
look at them and remember them for next
time so then the next time that she has
many Devils see these tumor cells
they'll be able to mount an immune
response against them because the immune
system will be what we call primed to
see these DFTD cells at the moment we're
working with the genome sequence and
with a large drug screen here at the
Sanger Institute and we've used hundreds
of candidate drugs and screened their
effectiveness in killing or preventing
proliferation of the Tasmanian Devil
cancer cells and we have found a couple
of very interesting candidates that
seems to be quite effective against the
devil cancer and we're now using these
drugs in Tasmania to see if they're
effective in Tasmanian devils against
the cancer